sehr geehrte Damen und Herren wir
befinden uns hier bei einer Schadstelle
in unserem Einsatzraum der
Gruppenkommandant der das
Gerätegruppe spitzleitner erklärt uns
genau was ihr passiert
die Hauptstraße und auf der linken Seite
haben wir acht verliste Personen mit
einem Baby gehört wurde und auf der
rechten Seite haben
erwachsene Person war jetzt ist der
Ansatz so dass wir mit unseren
ideologischen Ordnung zuerst beginnen
oder mehr vermisste sein auf der rechten
Seite im hinteren Schlafbereich weil das
hätte mir in der Nacht waren einen
hinteren Bereich die Ordnung mit der mit
einer suchen Rettungshunden beginnen
danach kann man mit technischen
bestätigen versuchen und auf der rechten
Seite
abgeschlossen ist machen wir auf der
rechten Seite weiter und versuchen den
Kontakt wieder herzustellen zu der
Person
erstmal so viele wie möglich Überlebende
aus diesen zwei geboren heraus retten
Schwergewicht auf der linken Seite noch
Personen und danach die rechte Seite
nicht untersuchen